hi this is International master David
preusse for chess comm and this is going
to be the first of two lectures about
King and pawn versus King and games now
a King and pawn versus King endgame is
only going to be a win if the person
with the extra pawn is able to turn that
pawn into a queen or a rook in other
words if they're able to get it down to
the end of the board and promote it to
another piece if not you are not able to
checkmate with a single pawn so don't
even bother trying so today we're going
to look at three sort of fundamental
questions to ask yourself when you get
to an endgame with a king in a single
pawn against I can't the first question
that you need to ask yourself is
actually just whether your pawn can walk
all the way down the board one step at a
time and become a queen without the
opponent's king interfering so in this
position here if it were White's move
they should in fact just push b6 and the
black King can't quite get there in time
to stop the pawn and so you Queen
without any assistance from your King
but let's say that the black King were
on this square here then on you would
count that one one two two three three
you're not going to be able to Queen
your pawn so you just have to answer
that question right away at the
beginning before you start trying to
maneuver with your King you just want to
know whether or not you're going to be
able to just walk the pawn down and
Queen it okay now here is the
fundamental position to understand for
King upon Endings White's pawn is one
step away from queening and blocked by
the black King so the question is is the
black King going to get out of the way
of the pond and let it Queen or is it
going to be able to block the pond well
this basically depends on whose move it
is and that is a crucial thing in end
games that you have a concept called
sueb slang which is that you have to
move and make your position worse so
let's say it's White's move here okay
white would be forced they can't move
the pawn because of black Kings blocking
so white would be forced to move his
King over here to c6 and
or to keep defending the pawn but in so
doing white creates a stalemate there's
no possible move for the black King here
and that's a draw
stalemate draw now let's go back here
and imagine that it is blacks move if
it's blacks move black only has one
legal move with their King why it's
controlling these squares here so the
black King is actually forced to step
out of the way of the pawn the white
King can advance and next move black
can't slot white from moving the pawn
forward and queening so look at this
position again for a moment and
understand if white has to move here he
has to move his King and make a
stalemate if he walks away black will
just take the pawn right so if it's
White's move it's a draw and if it's
blacks move white can actually win
because the black King has to step out
of the way and white makes progress and
that is su Guang okay and this is a
crucial crucial position to remember and
if you're in any position where the pawn
is a couple steps further back what
you're asking yourself is once my pawn
gets down to the seventh rank is it
going to be my turn my opponent's turn
right who's going to have to move their
King and let the other person get what
they want alright so I've got one more
position for you today to talk about now
again this is a position where it
matters who's move it is but the concept
I want to introduce to you here is that
when the Kings are staring at each other
like this this is called opposition okay
when there's one space in between them
and they're staring at each other like
this this is called opposition and if
your opponent has to move then we say
you have the opposition because it's
actually good for you for it to be your
opponent's move you want him to step
aside if you have to move then we say
your opponent has the opposition so look
imagine black has to move first their
King can't continue to control all three
squares that the white game could
advance to
so the king has to say step aside and
then the White King is able to flank the
black king and get closer to controlling
the square here and gain control of this
square so now the black King will move
back to block the White King and now
white can take the opposition again the
black King has to step aside again and
now the White King moves here or I could
do it differently for you this time the
black King can move this way and the
White King could move here and now you
see the white King has gained control of
all the squares he needs to escort this
pawn down the board and get a queen now
imagine instead that it is White's move
first in this position if it's White's
move first yes move his King and then
black can follow him and now black is
keeping the opposition the white King
moves the black King can block him
wherever he goes the black King steps in
the way and you see the black King keeps
the white King from walking around him
and controlling the squares in front of
the pawn so eventually if blacks able to
block the White King forever white is
going to have to make a pawn move ah and
that would bring us to the second video
on King and pawn vs. King where we'll
talk about it but first let me just say
that in general for this position here
if black has to step aside White's going
to win by flanking him and if White has
to step aside and has to move his pawn
forward in front of his King it's
actually going to end up as a draw I
hope you enjoyed this video and I'll see
you around on chess calm